there's no shortage of horror films in
the world but they all have one problem
they aren't real you know Freddy Krueger
won't really get you because he's just
Robert Englund in a mask werewolves
don't wreak havoc in London and there
are no sexy vampires who just want to
play sexy baseball it's the American
pastime know what you need in your
horror is a taste of real-life terror
here are some creepy documentaries about
the paranormal that are guaranteed to
get under your skin invasion on Chestnut
Ridge if you didn't know that Southwest
Pennsylvania is basically spook town
central USA you will after watching
invasion on Chestnut Ridge the latest
installment in the small town monster's
paranormal documentary series following
a high-profile UFO sighting an alleged
military cover-up in Kecksburg
Pennsylvania in the 1960s the area also
experienced a huge upsurge in Bigfoot
sightings in the 1970s heard a noise at
the back of her trailer and she opened
the door and Bigfoot was standing there
people living around Chestnut Ridge
reported seeing UFOs bizarre creatures
for years and the reports continued to
this day
this film traces the history of these
sightings across the decades through
first-hand accounts and chilling
reenactments the Mothman of Point
Pleasant also part of the small town
monster series the Mothman of Point
Pleasant investigates one of the
strangest events in the 20th century
over the course of 13 months in the
1960s the small West Virginia town of
Point Pleasant was home to numerous
sightings of a strange winged creature
which culminated in the deadly collapse
of the Silver Bridge the events of the
story have been dramatized in various
films including perhaps most famously
2002's the Mothman Prophecies
but the 2017 documentary the Mothman of
Point Pleasant takes a personal look at
the events through I witness interviews
and reports the movie is a deep dive
into the phenomenon that has become a
point of pride for the people of Point
Pleasant inspiring a statue a museum and
an annual festival other monsters wish
they had it so good
the nightmare this 2015 documentary
looks into the phenomenon of sleep
paralysis but as you watch it you'll
quickly realize that you aren't going to
get any dry boring facts in fact not a
thing
doctor or scientist is interviewed
throughout the film's 90-minute runtime
instead the nightmare sees eight
different individuals who have
experienced sleep paralysis describe
their experiences which are then
re-enacted to horrifying effect while
they're all bizarre the one that will
really stick with you is the shadow
people looming silhouettes who stand
over your bed while you lie helpless is
enough to inspire a few nightmares of
your own whether you experience leap
paralysis or not my Amityville Horror
chances are you're at least kind of
familiar with the Amityville Horror you
might have read the 1977 book by Jay
Anson or seen the 1979 film or it's 2005
remake but there's always room for one
more interpretation right my Amityville
Horror came out in 2012 and is the count
of the Amityville haunting from the
perspective of the now adult Daniel Lutz
who was only a child at the time of the
alleged haunting while the movie does
look at the haunting from his point of
view it's also a look at the way being
associated with a famous paranormal
story since childhood has affected
Daniels psychologically a haunting in
Connecticut and Georgia in 2002 the
Discovery Channel released two
feature-length specials Haunting in
Connecticut and a haunting in Georgia
which went on to inspire the
fictionalized theatrical release The
Haunting in Connecticut and its sequel
the improbably titled The Haunting in
Connecticut 2 ghosts of Georgia the
original TV documentaries recount the
alleged experiences from the
perspectives of the victims mixing
reenactments with narration and
interviews Connecticut deals with a
family moving into a house that was
formerly a funeral parlor there the
children begin seeing ghosts including a
demon they refer to as the man in the
suit this demon would tell him go
upstairs and do something bad
meanwhile Georgia deals with a family
who moves into an abandoned home only
for their four-year-old daughter to
begin communicating with a series of
imaginary friends in short if creepy
kids and they're spooky imaginary
friends give you the heebie-jeebies the
two pilot episodes of the now ongoing a
haunting series are probably just what
you're looking for the pantry ghosts
documentary the pantry ghost phenomenon
began with a series of YouTube videos in
2007 which a man claimed there was a
ghost opening his pantry door every
night at the same
time 12:34 a.m. the authenticity of
these videos has been hotly debated in
the decades since they first appeared in
2013's the pantry ghost documentary
expands and the alleged phenomenon
adding interviews with the man's family
and giving the background of how the
original videos came to be made it'll
definitely have you questioning how it
was done
whether by human or inhuman means ghosts
on the underground this eerie 2005
documentary doesn't rely on the usual
reenactments or jump scares it's mostly
a series of interviews with workers from
London's subway system the oldest in the
world and which the workers explain the
strange things they've seen and
experienced
there's no composited footage of what a
ghost might have looked like and no
actors just real people with real
stories the closest the film comes to
offering visual evidence of a ghost is a
man in an electric chair that appeared
in the background of a photo of a little
boy even so ghosts on the underground
covers some seriously creepy stories and
the film regularly inserts title cards
to remind you just how many people have
actually died down there which is spooky
enough on its own out of the blue are
there aliens among us that's the
question posed by the 2002 TV
documentary out of the blue a
feature-length film that calls itself
the definitive investigation of the UFO
phenomenon the film is packed with
interviews with experts from scientists
to eyewitnesses to high-ranking military
officials in an attempt to prove that
some unidentified flying objects
actually may have alien origins it also
looks at new alleged government attempts
to smother public belief in
extraterrestrials if alien encounters
and government conspiracies are more
your cup of tea than ghosts in the
pantry then out of the blue and its
sequel I know what I saw are probably
for you thanks for watching click the
looper icon to subscribe to our youtube
channel plus check out all the school
stuff we know you'll love to
[Music]